thanks a bunch
won a sausage nah I don't need pork are
you Jewish ain't Jewish man I just don't
even pork why not then throughout the
island was I don't eat filthy animal
sausage tastes good
pork chops tastes good I'm sue right my
tastes like pumpkin pie foo
I'll never know cuz even if it did I
wouldn't eat that filthy [ __ ]
pigs sleeping ruining [ __ ] that's a
filthy animal
I don't want to eat anything that ain't
got enough sense to disregard all feces
how about dogs dogs eat their own feces
I don't need dog either yes but do you
consider a dog to be a filthy animal I
wouldn't go as far as to call a dog
filthy but they're definitely dirty but
adults got personality and personality a
little lonely so by that rationale if a
pig had a better personality he cease to
be a filthy animal
we were talking about one [ __ ]
charmanders Pig it we has to be the Cary
Grant of [ __ ] pig was so full podcast
was so full podcast with Rodrigo Torres
right here Lisa over here chillin new
haircut she fixed the other haircut I
had a bad haircut and I think my my
stylist was emotional she's telling some
story telling some story this is that
what a month ago so what happened you
good she's crying she's telling some
story about her assistant and how her
assistant this little goth chick she's
real cool but I felt bad for the story
cuz she got institutionalized I mean
like yeah she was suicidal and all the
stuff and then they numbed her up with
drugs and she was all beside herself for
seeing her that way and but she's
telling me this that she's giving me the
worst hair could have had the worst
colored job I had that's that's what
Americans
so I was a little bit over like a month
I'd to go to San Francisco like that
everything I felt like [ __ ] so I finally
found this woman yeah this girl and I
felt bad but I felt like maybe you
should cancel this appointment she yeah
she was her assistant she's just weave
hair she washed my hair she would sweep
the hair she would give her color like
she would prep the color and stuff like
that but I don't know what happened but
I can't go back to that woman I just
can't
it felt so I felt like [ __ ] for weeks
piece I didn't want to wake up and have
to do my hair again because I didn't
know what to do I don't talk about my
flair she was part of the Nazi Gestapo
yeah more traumatic for women to get
their hair messed up in dudes I think it
could be fixed do you can shave your
head or cheek you can dog no no cab bro
because I'm but no writer now he oh but
now he's on point you're back and you're
happy you look younger too you know the
stars no more I don't know sergeant
Harris give her that book man would you
know sergeant Harris know what the book
was it was cost sergeant Harris fire the
cannon it was party boys like a rhyming
book with pictures but they never close
with something something fire the cannon
never had that for riff all right but
the monster in me upcoming show people
upcoming showed tonight March 2nd
tonight we're in Hilo Hawaii at the
Palace Theater
so hurry up man coming down there's
still plenty of seats available and I
mean plenty that's right Brad Saturday
March 3rd
Honolulu Hawaii at Blaisdell Center with
Paul Rodriguez
loulou Blaisdell Center with Paul
Rodriguez man altering Oh Donna I'm
trying to get ready for his trip brother
Rudy waiting [ __ ] because I don't want
to walk were there people think I live
there I don't want to be go Polly Polly
how many can you believe it here bro bye
bye where's the dog teacher Brewer
weather
[ __ ] that you're gonna show those
nipples or what I am out here dog the
whole time you get in the water with
socks in the water I'm so confident
after I [ __ ] Facebook ingrown toenail
[ __ ] I could walk on fire thought you're
gonna get some Crocs
hell no well you know what I am looking
for Crocs like rocks are cool but I
don't want Crocs like you know what the
kind of mario batali crowd but I do like
the dealer ones that are Crocs
I have some that look like slip-on vans
in their jocks they're waterproof and
they float really yeah so clearly
there's something at that yeah but man
you guys sure Steve right well at least
I know who she was she live with me
she's my wife
butt out dude my toe the left one I
don't know how he got like that maybe
was a 30,000 ever there's rooms in San
Francisco
no but cut your nail - it was like I'm
gonna get you sucker it was I'm gonna
get it was robbing but how bad it was -
I bumped into something
oh my god this is the worst I booked it
- subdued somebody broke and felt like
somebody hit me with a hammer bro it
felt like somebody stop me it was
getting nauseous it hurt so much huh
what yeah tuck right into the mic you're
caught talking away up here okay
[Laughter]
back to the Tonioli toenail it hurt
we're talking we're talking about the I
don't know why I change the story to
about these feet
we'll remember he had that big-ass black
toe that one time yeah but it wasn't an
ingrown toe no which is big eight I was
huge right there was like a camel nail
he was off he was all happy right he
admit his cheek I don't know vote on the
road or somewhere here matter and
Martine shows up to the to the against a
comedy condo or the hotel room and he
told me and I'm in hey man this girl is
dear Freddie
she's fun she's differently this girl is
different
they never I think I'm gonna be sad what
happened bro you sure your fear was she
called me Tony laughing I think it mondo
first scene a [ __ ] right and he passed
out bro it felt like bro like somebody
shoved uh at all your dumb know somebody
shows a potato on your thumb it was bad
it was big a well you should have that
guy I brought you that food drew your
rollerblades broke yeah but he gave me
the 2018 body dog I was released to roll
break when I was ten dog oh that's right
you were young and rollerblades came out
I was
these days no cool thing about Hawaii
they lost oh yeah then I go Marsh
mentally levered Phoenix a stand-up live
March 15th lowest ever take Cleveland
and hilarities March 23rd and 24th Los
Angeles at the noble downtown LA March
30 Austin Texas at Paramount Theatre
March 31st Atlanta Georgia at Variety
Playhouse lots more days check off a
liberal Worldcom slash tour for our
dates and ticket links shoutouts to see
stark 52 who like to cap jeep bonus
episodes days we should have an on a
local rapper Aston Myers local Matty's
will not get to a bro can a mile away I
guess
see start with the two other aspiring
manager thank you thank you
your member yoni graphics you gotta get
in there somewhere right smoke on the
active Aston Austin Myers after night
Matthew the brother smoke under WT r and
l are oh yeah no party Murano and inject
a magician electrician who gave us a
little talk to sue star review I am a
union electrician and I listen to your
podcast often I listen to when I work in
at home when I'm on a plane I listen to
it in the house I listen to it while
sitting with a mouse I listen to it when
I'm here do it when I'm there thank you
for listening Jack a poem had a short
circuit
what happened discover plagiarism why
see my son that's cool bro Thank You
felicity man the Jack the magician
electrician I guess he makes lights go
off
hell yeah all right so bro what's
helpful well fool so check and check
this time I didn't watch a doctor of
course right cuz you know me for what
the endo trona hell knows cuz I thought
I don't have a time bro and then
somebody told me that I don't know who
told me did your own surgery at the
house my publicist told me damn she
knows everything
Luis Guzman buddy I work yo mama Hama
get rid of this I'm over here in the
room I was over here dancing the tango
bring him a chapter so uh so I looked it
up bro so they say so I soak my feet in
warm water for a three times a day okay
cuz you got soften that milk is hard as
hell anybody ever listen you're Mary
Walker been limping for two years it's
goes out for you too
anybody with the bloody dog I wonder you
know how we're gonna get under that to
pull it back out
yeah so Google said gift floss and I
don't mean still a make little Bernie so
you guys forgot flies was my nail will
stop and I pull that thing back with it
with the floss practicing every day bro
with the fly that I finally got it out
and now grow I'm walking like a
ballerina
I go kick a wall bro these literally are
bunions though whatever I think that
crazy three have enough story to tell
because Kramer finds out you sold all
his stories to mr. Peters man
this is when Kramer finds a oh that's
right never mind sorry that was I'm
talking about the [ __ ] when he finds the
Mike Douglas quit quit I mean when he
found the set for Mike the Mike Douglas
show I'm reversing show and then he sets
it up in his apartment and then he's
bored and because they're they're
running out of stuff to talk to you
right out of guests and then he says -
he says to Newman he Newman starts
talking and he's like no they just had
bunion stories yeah something like that
right yeah but that one too he had
bought some Bunyan story he bought some
burgers two different episodes I forgot
anyway whatever but you corrected it
though if you fixed it I can't believe
it yeah man I saw everybody listening
out there man I have the ingrown toenail
doctor now
and man and everybody was bad feet man I
know yeah I love people don't have
health insurance man I'm just like man
it soak your feet in water okay every
day
hot warm water and without vinegar maybe
also three times a day and practice
pulling your feet back you told back
every day your toenail and get a floss
and dig in there man every day every day
every day every day all your feet every
day every day then little by little man
you start singing and they'll start
going back straight and that's a bunion
story for the first person and the
podiatrist were so full man we're gonna
read a couple of quotes right here
before we introduce our guests I got
prepared this time matter this time I
didn't just get the names wrong and
start putting people that were born in
Long Beach when they were already born I
have no desire to be a politician I
don't want to lead anyone I have no
practically go I have
not ambitious I merely want to do what
is right once in every century there
comes a man who has chosen to speak for
his people
Moses Morrow and Martin are examples
who's to say that I am NOT such a man
and this day and age the man for all
seasons Eve's many voices per half that
is why the gods have sent me into
riverbanks Panama San Francisco Alpine
and Juarez for Hafner and Wyatt I've
been taught so many trades who would
deny that I am unique for months for
years
not all my life I start to find out who
I am why do you think I became Baptist
why did I try to force myself into the
riverbank swimming pool and did I become
one and then I become a lord just to
prove to the polishing I could do
something worthwhile an idiot that sees
only the obvious is blind for God's sake
I have never seen and I have never felt
inferior to men to any man or beast the
man was never comfortable unless he was
in the company of people who were
crazier than he was and when he roared
into your driveway at night you knew he
was bringing music whether you wanted it
or not any combination of a 250-pound
mexican lsd-25 is a potentially terminal
manner for anything that can't reach and
that is Oscar's that our Costa
autobiography of a brown Buffalo and for
those of you who are listening to me
right now just you got letting you know
that um I'm our guest right here you
know I'm not gonna make the map but I I
did have I do have a book that I had um
then I'm the Oscars Etta across the road
anything it's in my book right here I'm
just gonna find it to make sure ain't no
poser I got it right here somewhere and
it's right here yeah I was a fool for
here man
I read 50% of it it says right here
and it's um I don't want to show up but
and it is bad here but it's the revolt
of the cockroach people yes I have it in
my book
what's up fool we have Phillip Rodriguez
right where yes and we have hero and
directed an awesome documentary about a
person you guys don't bother leave it to
look up or never bother to mention this
guy's not even and um in the history
books like you gotta like you you gotta
find it like though to find out about
Oscar death Acosta sometime man you
gotta find it by watching fear and
loathing then you gotta look could you
really like the movie I look ok man this
kind of let's pay me needs to do real do
or something then you find out in the
real [ __ ] how did you find out
about you you're a college grad yeah I
found about him for that movie and I
heard about them and this course called
history of American racism taught by
Elliott Bork and the chicken he's won
all that stuff and then we went to that
exhibit at the Museum still going on by
the way till next February 2019
are you serious I thought I was gonna be
it's still going on Autry museum and
telling me I heard about on what's a
full podcast yeah give him a little
donation only exhibit you got to see
there I mean all the photos from the
exhibit are we from the beginning of the
magazine we have a fillable three days
here I brought the right involve the
brown buffalo documentary about ostrich
etiquette or Chicano civil-rights
activist author attorney also produced
by Benicio del Toro Philip is an
award-winning documentary filmmaker who
has made field for PBS for years father
to return in Los Angeles but it gets a
little broke man yeah man what's up boo
what's up whenever I walk into a room
there's people who know who Oscar is I
immediately feel I'm up with friends
more comfortable and you know the guy
deserved more recognition than he got he
was fantastic like so many Chicanos this
was a big man there's a big man with a
big soul and a big ego and a big project
and a big ambition and big madness and a
big bonza and [ __ ] was just
totally marginalized he's invisible and
and it's ridiculous that a guy like this
is a footnote and we're just trying to
correct it do you think it was because
he's too wild I think he was because he
was too Brown I think it was because was
why he was too smart he was too
threatening he was and for the polite
little Chicanos hater where the
university once he was a little too
rough and rattle Chino and he was very
attended he would have the opposite of
Martin Luther King and kind of not as
not as straight like Malcolm X's motto
method to do drugs yeah I mean he was
here is we huh he was had a lot of edge
in a lot of wildness and it was horny
and he you know he ate a lot of burritos
but when you think about the way they
wrote the civil rights history it's
always recently people right trying to
do the right thing they were just trying
to get laid you know Oscar said you know
the revolution doesn't have to be a drag
and I think that's the kind of symbol
that the kids at this point need you
know cuz they think about the civil
rights people it's all these sainted
people you know god bless to Lotus or
Caesar or whatever but Oscar never won a
hunger strike
so yeah so I'm excited to be here and I
watched your HBO show the other day when
maybe it was Showtime but but it was so
funny and it is you're right and I've
recognized my own people when I saw you
and I saw Oscar and you and the
intelligence the exuberance the anger
the the wild way of speaking and really
that's those you're you're my people and
you also might Tokyo so by the way oh
yeah I saw this morning okay so last
night I got so tired and I was doing
work trip but I wanted like when I win
which the dog went to go see the exhibit
there was a little bit of Austrian
prominence but there was another guy
there that you probably know him because
you seem to know a lot a lot of stuff
about the Chicano Movement more than I
know but remember like gather to book it
at CSUN oh yeah Reese no Reese yeah yeah
yeah yes all right I didn't know that I
already know who the Imbaba Chicano
Movement but he was his face was all
over all over the photos and we think I
know him because I used to put up a
comedy show for him and all that money
is to go for scholarships Theresa was
one of the cofounders of Ferris blossom
magazine magazine and a very kind of
heroic photographer who put his neck out
there took a lot of pictures that
without Reese and a lot of his cohort we
wouldn't have any record of that era it
would all be crazy lies and stories and
men theatres and as it is you know
because the because the history is so
invisible because histories of people
women and non-whites really matters a
lot less than the history of the people
that the people that control things
right the histories they and only they
have the means of dissemination of
production of making films of green
lighting projects TV shows publishing
books and there are stories the ones
that get surprised that be considered
the ones that are important
traditionally and obviously the
implications of this are pretty pretty
pretty profound and pretty terrible
because if you don't see yourself as an
pourtant you're gonna really ingest the
idea that you are indeed secondary that
you don't have any agency that it's
hopeless for you to even try to act
because you don't [ __ ] matter because
you are a [ __ ] [ __ ] and I mean that
in a pejorative old-school way that so
it's ya gotta insist on as you guys do
sit around here and talk and and and and
on your own spin and your own narrative
and so I'm just trying to introduce
people that really have value I think
not just that's the past artifact but
something that we can use in the present
moment some when he's this fools coming
in on the dacha kids you know you got to
have somebody who's chingon enough he's
got enough [ __ ] balls madness love to
step the [ __ ] up and get into the face
of these pricks that are coming at you
so that kind of inspires the the
conversation that I wanted so that's how
hardcore Oscar was in no time
Oscar was armed Oscar had a foot but I
I'm gonna tell you doctor made a fool he
raised a gun in the room in the court in
the courtroom you know in the courtroom
he come in on mescaline
he'd have drugs and he had this attache
case it was with decals and flowerpower
all over it and he'd come in this
council to this court me come on
barefoot sometimes to show absolute
disrespect on one day he walked into the
courtroom with Hawaiiana right and the
judge says mr. Acosta approach the bench
this is not acceptable clothing for a
courtroom Oscar said excuse me sir
that's a real good Ingo attitude in my
country a guayabera is a formal wear and
I'm an insist upon my right to do that
well Oscar ended up going to jail for
contempt but in a way out of it for away
no wider right so I like the guy because
he's rebellious but like you said before
he's not serious like like Malcolm and
not to say Malcolm's not valuable
because he is but Oscar is ours either
everyday men in some ways you know he
was he was he was and he was also had
this gritty quality of being transparent
about himself
he was he was he was uncomfortable with
his big mestizo cylindrical body and he
or do three jackets
he's so cylindric you like it good and
so he was just kind of he was raw you
know isn't true he wasn't he wasn't a
saint he was a regular person and with a
lot of flaws and a lot of defects and he
was probably bipolar and crazy as [ __ ]
my favorite part is when he goes into
the bar let's see he goes for a spit bro
by himself don't deal in Mexico for
walks to Utley goes I'm the trouble but
see I could see ya did you did you did
you relate to that identity of her talk
to me about that
I really America though everybody in the
world has said you should I was born
from that real when I was a bastard some
guy told me that here some guy told me
that to get that book the revolt of the
cockroach people because he said man
there's there's ever a movie man or a
play you could play that guy he goes
alright for there I found out that he
was the guy that wasn't named called the
wall Simone thank you so remember
bankers down I remember in my stand-up
comedy like like I like people don't
like you like what happened when I wrote
that like right now some of that
material a lot of people get sad you
know they get to bigger to hurt that
what I mentioned their social justice
social justice warrior when I mentioned
that out that I'd like that I'm with
that that we have racism in our own
culture to man like when I say that um
whenever we see a darker Mexican we look
at her who invited that who would wear
that my choco beat them right and I stay
like and it to be funny funny I said to
me funny good is true all right but some
people just embrace it
he's promoting opera color wisdom now
instead of opening the door to
discussing them and the truth instead of
let's find out why then then find out
why Telemundo never ends abriendo or
thorak african-american there is black
Mexicans why do i why is it there are
black Mexican and now see sports I think
they're black Colombian those are shot
in we won't question that with the
general question about how did you get
me off the air and I feel like now this
dude was matter how Oscar was because he
like everybody wanted like everybody
wanted like um to surround himself with
only smaller intellectuals instead of
being around the real people who who
actually need the help
now fufu that food got all the cholos
together bro you know then all those are
me I wake I always call these guys at
31,000 because uh because you know
Terminator Terminator they're
mexican-american but you the new
versions you know they come with degrees
you know they don't like blood that
movie blood in blood out they think
American me shouldn't be part of our
culture well there is a movement afoot
Wow big a movement but within the Latino
social justice warriors that you see and
and this is not every Chicano activists
or Latino activists at all but there's a
small percentage that just take
everything too far and it closes doors
it gets people to stop if people tune
you out are you crazy
oh they're not together yeah and there
is a movement also by those same people
to split Chicano into old-school Chicano
and new-school Chicano and like these
old-school Chicanos are these people who
think like that if people they like it's
almost like looking down on people who
might have been who might be a vet that
I know now you know what you know or
they sold drugs at one point you know
like because that doesn't promote
positive to kind of values but this is
part of the fabric of the whole our
world we're in a stage of becoming gotta
figure that most Latinos that are here
come
after like after the 1965 Immigration
Act right so the most Latinos in this
country by the great proportion of them
come in the 80s we given eighties all
right we can't I should get my green
card say 81 there we go so good I came
over here we're on a rig before Ron Ron
acetic Ronald Reagan before under Reagan
did the crazy law their mistake all the
really fix 1986 we got ready for him so
you know we're just new
we're just settling into this place and
to think that we're gonna be completely
polite or completely organized or
completely have one mind as stupidest I
mean we're just brand new people think
about the Jews that 5000 years talking
to each other wandering around the
desert learning how to read practicing
their prayers we aren't just started so
obviously it's gonna be messy obvious
gonna be ridiculous sometimes obviously
it can be conflictual it should be and
and we have to stop being so [ __ ]
polite and so doctrinaire and just mix
it up a little bit and have and this is
why what you all do here is great
because it's conversation that's loose
and informal and intelligent and free
and we have to speak freely and that's
one of the reasons as a comedian so I
think they're so valuable now because
you guys can cross those lines that
others can't and do it in a way that's
appealing to people and Oscar had that
kind of quality right just bring it
bring reality what was your background
would you talk I'm from LA like
grandparents I was raised I was born in
South San Gabriel and then mindedly and
then I kinda got over to we I well they
moved me to Glendale when I was a boy
and Glendale at that time it was the
headquarters the American Nazi Party
from 1965 to 1982
so when I was a boy I mean seriously at
second grade I remember when an American
Nazi power yeah I mean a bunch of
[ __ ] knuckleheads and they to march
around and give out pamphlets and say no
[ __ ] pixon and it was a sundown town
into the 50s which meant that if you
drove through if you were non-white and
you were there after dark or at in
Glendale they would roll up the cop
would roll up in a bike and say Sonny
get the [ __ ] out so you couldn't be
there
after dark my father and mother we were
very dark-skinned family still are and
and and and they put us there in a good
neighborhood so it was very interesting
and I remembering glowing second grade I
had to piss when to the little urinal
little boys urinal and a couple boys got
around the side of me and looked at my
peepee and of course they were after
they got over the shock of its enormity
they they said wow that's brown - so you
know was really was the other and you
learn about white people in a really
great way when you're when you're an
environment like that I don't know why
start you asked me why I was from so
that's why I'm from my parents were all
my grandparents were Mexicans look no
I've eaten is show up means don't show
up until the way later again so it's
super white bread from 82 or white
people have bought our bolting even my
mom she still lives there and she has me
hold you know these Armenians I'm not so
sure about them but she says sometimes I
miss the racist good Ingles instead of
the races Armenians you know they're
finding their way to right they're
pushing shoving and they're insecure and
they don't know where they're at and
they got their little movie that's going
on and they're like any group think
about the Koreans before the riots I
don't know I may just go to Koreatown
I'd get thrown out of bars because they
didn't want anybody but their own they
were paranoid they were afraid and of
course they got into a Bronco with the
blacks right because they didn't
understand african-american behavior and
the whole thing blows up but now you go
to Koreatown they're chill they're
comfortable and so you know everybody's
got to find their way here and got an
elbow each other out and and understand
who your neighbor is know how to how to
get along with each other and how to
thrive and I think la is great right now
don't you think
do you like I mean that the whole
polyglot immigrant mixture yeah really
good you're very quiet over there but
just taking it on Riverside man
yeah but the men are made we're uh where
did I where did a pretty get acclimated
to uh Oscar yeah you know Oscar is one
of those things
mom was friends with Oscar sister I went
to college and I read his book and you
know it it was fascinating to me and so
I really wanted to make a picture time
ago you said your father's an attorney
my father was an attorney also yeah yeah
my father was an attorney and a
mexican-american attorney in that era
right right and I remember him telling
me one day about a big fat Mexican who
showed up to court with bare feet and
you know so he was okay any and he
didn't the proof of him necessarily
thought he was a little bit you know
nasty but I'm using yeah cuz I know he's
Wow but I still treat him as an
intellectual because he had a lot of
great ideas
oh listen that's what I'm saying the guy
was marvelous he was [ __ ] strong he
was he was a he was a very good in the
courtroom but he was also you know he
was wild and you can be both things
that's the right right and that's
there's so many different things to be
special you're Mexican I know there's a
lot of Mexican people said oh I always
had my teachers I was always like white
cops in my first in elementary school my
principal was Mexican our district
eternity was Mexican so it was different
for me I always seen those posess to me
it wasn't like a chip of my shoulder
coming out to the world now I got a
[ __ ] piece of these white people and
you also see different types of white
people not just that one white person
that's you know racist or whatnot
sure I mean I got white people on my
family and I'm load them and they're my
people and there's I just know that that
contradiction because obviously as we
elevate and we become more as used to
success part more the leadership of
things then we become it's it's it's
less conflictual until a man like this
told lights now feel like they're under
it actually right now well again it
rotated back they wrote they rotated
back because basically one guy Lyndon
Johnson once said this is this is like a
political strategy he once said if you
can convince the lowest white man that
he's higher than the highest black man
you can pick his pockets forever and
that's exactly what there is what
happened now because when these white
people saw Obama elegantly a Harvard Law
Review and [ __ ] walking up the stairs of
Air Force One and they're [ __ ]
struggling to pay for their pop-tarts
whatever the [ __ ] they're doing they
flip their [ __ ] you know basically
assaulted their fundamental sense of
whatever less dignity they got
so when they witness this that it just
did undermine the let the rest of their
American Dreams and shambo's precisely I
mean they got less money they got less
health care they got less everything big
loss less prestige houses are harder to
buy their kids are on oxy [ __ ] cotton
living the lives of their parents
generation in the Air Force one and you
know that they come undone and one thing
cool is my muscle rug Pune her he was an
activist he was actually speaking up
when their kids were getting my keys
with me though and that's what a lot of
people weren't doing that cuz you know
we're more of a passive cult read I mean
but he like kind of like rot for about
my dough I mean kind of like you know
the pastor but that's a great point that
you make that the passivity of our
people that we're kind of almost
pathologically inclined toward
conciliation and afraid of conflict
right and that's a problem we just write
work it's - it's a problem because you
got it listen I mean you got to get in
people's faces you know precisely do you
think that comes from being part of
families who did come here as immigrants
and they don't want to rock the boat I
think it comes from the effects of
colonialism yeah when all of a sudden
you're swarmed by new people with a new
set of order and you're dislocated and
think about man the indigenous people of
Mesoamerica the mestizos you don't know
what you face in the social order is you
got a rough authoritarianism it's kind
of dominating you and making you feel
ashamed the black hats you know wiping
you out with self shame race shame body
shame and Asians - mother afraid and
they were color cops they don't build in
Chinatown they get yelled at
oh yeah like I think I think Chinese
people get pushed by their boss it well
they're a Yoda in their face they just
put their head down go to work yeah and
that's a class every but they were five
back cuz in Mexico there all day bro all
day like I bet you join a restaurant
when I got there and the same guy is
there called a nobody no better no
stupid
you know you could you know supposed to
be here eight hours right now nice to me
because right here you have class like a
class system I mean it's not as hard
quarters in Mexico Mexico feeding got no
money you can hang out people that have
money here's different you know a rich
everybody knows a rich guy basically you
can say yeah whatever it is you got
family there you know but ready but
mothers ain't got real money I'm talking
about that real ass money I mean you
can't hang out with them it's just not
gonna happen
they not read poor people there's no way
Chapel will be in the same room with
Russell Peters and that's blatant out
there I mean and just look at look at
everybody on TV look at even their
political leadership they're all mostly
white you know absolutely so you know we
haven't had our crack at it yet since
since the time before the you know
Columbus and Cortes survived the misty
so we've been on kind of on the bottom
of a totem pole and we continue to be
but you have to what I love it you can
be like a minute like you step on the
stage and you're not making apologies
for anybody
you're just a rude fries bilking you
don't you're not malevolent but you're
gonna do your thing and the way you're
gonna do it and that kind of posture is
what Oscar had is what I think that I
think we should encourage I don't want
to don't be rude but you can be rude to
you know the big toes the squeaky wheel
gets the [ __ ] grease and so that's
another thing I like about this guy
Oscar is it he doesn't give one [ __ ] you
know and he's not gonna back down
and he's absolutely fundamentally
because he's by boy bipolar crazy
[ __ ]
he doesn't [ __ ] care and was there any
relationship with him and Cesar Chavez
and all that other stuff I think that
you know vaguely I mean vaguely the
thing is yeah yeah sure those guys had
some kind of knowledge of one another
but Cesar is rural
rights farmworkers which my grandparents
were they picked fruit up and down the
coast and they were always
agriculturists but Oscar was an urban
animal like all of us now Latinos did
the whole mythology that were like
that's our Chavez picking up [ __ ] you
know that's no longer the case
you know man we're suburban people yeah
man and an Oscar was like us he ached
[ __ ] sandwiches out of the god
refrigerator you know and he didn't pick
nothing he'd picked when he was a kid
but you know he was Arab and Jackie was
college educated I see that you get
punched out of the gallon bro oh great
he was I was at least a day he liked to
Wed us he liked nagging us you know you
he was he was all good for him he wasn't
he wasn't he wasn't perfect man he was
it he was an it was a you know an animal
I like that when you learn in a
documentary you used to trust on parts
that a lot of people in will never admit
like when he said that he never spoke
Spanish you know there's a lot of people
who don't speak Spanish right now who
front they you know her happy okay we're
gonna member have Ted Cruz in my Rubio
but anyways but you know they front like
Rubio speak Spanish yeah but Cruz
doesn't well then oh wait a minute they
ask yeah I think what tell about food he
didn't know right in the thing about
Mexicans Mexicans don't care other makes
it okay don't speak Spanish they just
care are you down yeah I say I said we
care about we don't care if you're third
generation fourth generation we don't
care whoever mana battle or you grew up
in beagle Union if you're down you're
down if you can't speak Spanish that's
cool okay I'm gonna be down I was with
my brother and we were in my house to
meet there and and and and Mayor Antonio
was there giving a speech in Spanish and
we're watching yeah give me speech um
and it was Bob Shaw Spanish like mine
right and I was felt so proud that he
was just [ __ ] it up and bungling it
like I would you know but go for broke
did about making the wrong words and
[ __ ] and I felt like that's my Spanish
and I'm I'm proud of it you know baby
that ain't too bad from a total from
city terror see I went to I went to
Berkeley and there was this guy used to
work in the statue Cano got it he he
represented himself as the most Chicano
of all Chicana thought he was a purity
Cano and the only [ __ ] word he knew
inside of say in Spanish was sabe skank
and every other thing he'd say we
guys like that harp on that little
longer to longer comedians one-inch I
know there's a but I feel like with
activism and sort of activism I I don't
understand why there have to be rules
there are rules about how you should
behave so you say people say would
describe him as a flawed
you know he's flawed for an activist
right but what is flawed you know what
are the rules for being an activist
because I said about feminism you know
and people there are women who come down
women who want to be a housewife who
want to be a housewife they don't want
to work they want to raise kids they
want to get married to want to do that
on you I'm telling you for me it's
always been about choices having eat the
choices in life it begins and ends there
for me as a feminist but there are all
these other rules that people come in
you're not acting and once you have a
[ __ ] animal like this guy between the
president this [ __ ] pig this rabid
sack of [ __ ]
no that's the notion the notion that we
would cut we would ask women to have a
higher standard than this [ __ ] animal
is it's great so tell me it's getting
better I know yeah Reese that's what I
like about that professor from a CSUN
he's not out there every day on his
Facebook talking about what he did or do
yeah right a lot of act so-called
activists right now in this particular
day names I'm a t-shirt every day on
Twitter and I go what are you doing
nothing but being a job I mean seriously
I mean I'm covered by activism if your
landlord in somebody gets hurt we're
gonna give them free rent some people
think they did by posting a voter all
about apathy oh sorry I say that you
grew up eating it Lefter activism for
the day are you for two hours a day at
your house teaching kids how to read the
neighbors how to read get them an access
to information get it I mean come on
that stuff that you're gonna get
necessarily paid for everybody wants to
get paid for for the activism and he
wants to get like for that's what I see
no sure they want to get they're gonna
get gold stars late and they want to be
get pat on the back and and and and when
indeed some of these old Chicano guys
meant they spent
they're the guys that ran away when the
[ __ ] got hard and now they're the ones
you see every weekend giving the speech
convening little talks to talk tell you
how great they were and they were just
[ __ ] people so I don't even know
photos ya know and that's a jam do that
they were able to salvage all that
document what they did but that's that's
what I'm saying about people that
actually are doing something they're
doing it out of the kindness of their
heart how they're believing you know I
mean you know believe it in Jesus Christ
and all that but you can actually share
with your brothers oh there cuz there
was also a Hungarian kid they got shot
and kid killed with right there by the
cop and guarantee you I think yeah and I
mean that that goes before he's put in
his neck out for everybody that's you
know living the neighborhood to see was
to so we can't forget dudes like not
sure that guy wasn't an informant oh
really
yeah if he was that's what you get news
plan but um nevertheless yeah that was a
couple years ago yeah another figure
from that era that again you do his dev
effector Oscar a lot sure I'm infected a
whole bunch of them because they slow
down their movement you know it wasn't
the revolutionary guys that got killed
it was his middle-class Jewish guilt and
these other heroes most of them just
went into hiding because you know if
that can happen to this dude what's
gonna happen to me maybe yeah sure I
mean it and it and it also tells you how
deep the conviction may or not may not
have been Oscar doubled down after that
and he went hard and he called in Hunter
Thompson and he said hunter I need you
to write about this you have access to
Rolling Stone magazine this is a crazy
thing precisely so Oscar went on the
offensive in a big way
after that a lot of these so-called
people that traipse around like they
were heroes when underground or just
went low-key but Oscar amped it up
because it seems like it kind of died
after that right I think I think I think
a lot of things died you know I think
you know once the white kids stopped
getting drafted they left they went back
to the middle class
hustle those baby boomers that were so
active in the anti-war movement
once the draft stops they have no stake
in women's rights anymore they have no
stake in black rights anymore they're
going back to being straight up white
peckerwoods and going for the gold a lot
of those guys ended up in corporate
positions I know that guy who started
the tofutti company and his friend and
that guy used to live on the farm in
Tennessee like the hippie farm the
kommune he runs took well I don't know
about now he's retired properly but he
was running tofutti corporation in New
Jersey it was weird like and he was all
about like you know that fast-paced
lifestyle that a lot of the guys run one
to make you know and love it and I just
read a biography about yawn win or the
guy that founded Rolling Stone magazine
I just people made fortunes nearly
billions hustling the revolution but
that's always gonna be the case
yeah you know you still got to act as
you suggested try to speak truthfully
and do the right thing where the people
can find any when it comes out were they
gonna find it March 23rd thank you very
much my 21st at 9 p.m. 23rd
yeah and so it's gonna the great thing
is that that the network provides it's
gonna be seen in every market so it's
not just teaching Chicano history but
this was three before but this is for
everybody so some some nut'n knuckle
knuckle head in and in in Memphis or in
Green Bay Wisconsin or a young person 13
year old white girl you know or see an
Aryan they're all gonna be have access
to this part of our history into a
character that's more like us than done
a lot of right they know did you speak
to anybody that out that that was that
told you how our pissed-off Oscar was
what he called him a 300 some more time
making him Chicano cuz I I always
thought I was a woman always personally
I always never like when they do that I
when they take a role so it meant for
somebody but then they change it so much
that become something else you become
something now told him whatever he
really was we saw that I saw the
documents and I talked to him Oscar's
lawyer who was a friend just Jewish guy
Neal herring and he described how full
of rage and felt betrayed Oscar felt an
Oscar sued threatened to sue released
magazines so stop the publication of
Fear and Loathing in fact he stopped the
making of the first film about fear and
loathing successfully because he was so
pissed off at hunter and so Rolling
Stone and its affiliates came to Oscar
and said hey we we got it we had a
problem right he says yeah we got a
problem
well what if we give you a book deal and
out of that conflict out of that
threatened lawsuit Oscar got a book deal
to make his two terrific he was
basically Oscar was claiming I own 50%
of fear in love yeah and if you don't
give it to me I will not allow you to
publish this so he muscled up on these
dudes and that's where his loyal lawyer
training came in handy and got himself
the book and it really without those
books we wouldn't be talking about
Auster we wouldn't know a whole lot of
that era so he did us a favor
unfortunately Oscar was really a mess
you know wait why do they mention so
much the Lord would see the Chavez they
mentioned JFK a robbery of Kay how come
no no no nothing about him like well
then they were like a you know a mural
was in here a mural somewhere because
away why are your children are taught
that why don't nobody messes him like
it's a you know listen bro just kind of
part for your we're dogs this lawyer was
[ __ ] battling like was fighting cases
or nobody wanna take oh yeah man what's
your answer to that question my answer
that is that there was a not necessarily
that there were passive but they were
creating the Union it was a Farm Workers
Union and you attach it to the
Democratic Party and then you attach
that they're Mexicans from here that
could vote so then there you have that
that's why I think there's political and
listen Dolores Huerta is establishment
she was a tone the Hillary Clinton
circle right so she's an establishment
Democrat established apparatchik of a
major party and so she's useful to them
she's useful to rich people to rich
white people that run the Democratic
Party they make most of the decisions
about the Democratic Party but try to do
it on the backs of non-whites and
non-white votes so and they were against
illegal immigration you call them what
they call the weapons they used to beat
up the scabs it would have been
were actually from Mexico that go in
there take those positions were so hurt
her presence her identity flatters
whiteness in some way
Oscar wasn't in that business and
they're necessary conformance but I
think also at the same time you have
people other mexican-american groups who
were in the establishment who wanted to
ignore someone like Oscar to themselves
you know and they helped him get well
yeah like that fits all the still times
of Mexicans wrong well it's the same as
like you know ask a Mexican not covering
you when you want unless Comic Standing
we're talking about it yeah welcome to
the back who's gotta go no Syrian I know
seriously it was called ask a mess kit
and what time when I want let's comment
standing I totally sorry he's not that
guy
I see ones do a little article about a
Mexican winning Last Comic Standing no
response nothing like I guess I didn't
fit four years of graduating college
criteria yeah a degree in Chicano
Studies but now but we are not bad with
the main guy right here I think that a
lot of you know that's what they call
bursts of gear respectability politics
they were trying to get appear to be
respectable in the eyes of whites and
the eyes of each other I mean like the
people I went to people from money this
woman who used to be the head of MALDEF
and Oscar was a lawyer from all deaf and
I asked her can you place it she wanted
nothing to do with Oscar so there was a
whole bunch of those fancy Mexican
Americans of that generation that just
turned their back on Oscar most of them
did because until until Trump started
coming around and they realize oh man
we've given up way too much and so maybe
we can be make use out of Oscar in terms
as it as a rebellious figure because
they'd forgotten how to fight I mean a
lot of that generation know they're
making money now they're in they're in
the chips Democratic Party forgot how to
fight the guy that the guy that founded
the National Council at us he send his
kids like and over the bunch of best
schools and stuff so they turned they
turned the Chicano hustle into you know
elite status I had a chance to go to
that school by the way
well now I know they know
our suite of junior high school
everybody applied for four different
private schools and I have to want to
say yes to me
but since I was like living in the
housing projects also explain to a more
funky [ __ ] leg horse-like unless you
just turn me off
really I will not be here oh you're
right you probably have a hell yeah
mentioned that you'd have a Tesla too so
that's what we're showing this film
after that gets over the PBS round by
the way so so you're right right now
yeah I think I'm right most the time and
also you did a documentary with George
Lopez - yes are you know George oh yeah
we you know well I'm not well we're
gonna do no mo what do you think let me
get a Houston Astro say yes I'd like
George what's the world series George
and Joey like them
he's a funny [ __ ] oh yeah next
time asking for two tickets yeah we made
out man now 1989 to 2000 when you're
holding que locos he's been good to you
- yeah that's good yeah see he's been
good to Philly fan so a lot of people
who say oh he doesn't help other Latino
comics real those whack-ass comedian
named Cisco and he was crying right that
Jordan like he kept me keep keep me
emailing and tweeting George Lopez on
Twitter over and over like a big [ __ ]
okay it's a big [ __ ] and he goes amen
how get help on that roster on a roster
how do you do that I'm gonna do that you
do this and then now and then I even
though that piece the [ __ ] guy and I
said it's a bro how come you're gonna
bother this guy you know how why should
he do you go chick um sign for Twitter
right now who has course because he only
Jews are begging right now
for more money for the rabbi will take
this rod go how many people are asking
him for money right now it seemed like
it seemed like a little it's like a a
Chicano or mexican-american or or a
Cuban guy a Peruvian guy cannot be
successful without [ __ ] people
leeching like oh oh you're not doing
that people are nice I brought me being
up here is doing a lot for last
yeah for me like even when people say
that all power of Julian every day not
internet that piece of [ __ ] comedian
saying that George did not in retirement
his presence is doing enough
she's like Black Panther Black Panthers
presidents is doing a lot for young
african-american who never had out who
never thought you could be a superhero
Panahi teens yeah Matt could be a
superhero oh hell yeah I'm not just
black man you see a few black girls
Lopez or Black Dynamite it's brown and
[ __ ] he's up there representing yeah
that was George destroy any and what
[ __ ] then he goes Torre mention about
George Lopez instead he gives hope for a
lot of people because he's dark he's a
dark Mexican just like early it's like
[ __ ] now what's the name Oscar he's a
dark fat Mexican who represent us and in
you know what and in Georgia never would
you say about there was no way that will
be famous in Mexico the way he lose but
but then on top of everything else when
he first busted out when he got super
famous he was funny
that doesn't Rodney Dangerfield funny
and I mean I just like blowing it up
yeah I mean the amount of people that
come up to you that I come up to you
after shows or say to on social media
stuff you make me proud to be Mexican
like you know I mean they find something
in you that makes them proud all hail to
George for real George is good right now
so basically Torrez you produce your
movie um Benicio I was all confused
a little best Benicia stepped in and was
was we went to Berkeley I went to
Berkeley Underground yeah undergraduate
yeah my first ever comedy show in
Berkeley where around for some students
I got booked $450 no I was so excited
anyone asked is there a hotel and I will
for a guy named and they was killed her
and I perform and teller was a student
yeah Michael Ford is a little pale
no way he put he's get put his own show
together I had let her do the school
nothing bro how'd it go man I don't know
well I was fine about but then I got
cold at night where doors day did you
really have nowhere to stay
gets cold in the Bayboro bad yeah so
what Berkeley is a great place only been
do you know I've been been doing these
for about 20-some years I think well how
about it went to UCLA film school and
I'm I figured like this I'm like I like
I like I'm documenting real stories how
long did it take you to put this one
together oh this one who picked up a few
years you know I've been thinking about
it for about 20 years and and you know
what wanted to but somebody else had the
rights or this person had to write some
movie actors had the rights people
trying to make a film about Oscar for
many years oh and not successfully
because there's in a traditional kind of
conventional Hollywood format you'd have
to cast a big fat Mexican and there's no
big fat Mexican to a box-office right so
we had to do it in a way that you didn't
where you didn't need someone that was
famous to cast him you had some of the
footage we used wasps are the real Oscar
and we combine it with performance of
someone who's kind of plain the Oscar so
um yeah I Bob have wanted this a long
time it's been kind of a dream come true
and I'm really happy and feel lucky that
I got to do this you also with your
films you do the produced as far as
getting the funding yeah I praise the
money yeah basically on top of it being
released by PBS I'm sure they give you a
little bit you know they build CPB we
gave a lot of okay I was actually lucky
because there was a Chicano from San
Antonio who was in the position of
authority which never happens
and I went to pitch him and he said
Santa brown buffalo is I got a first
edition in life and my and my home
library and I was just fantastic and so
he understood what I was after I
understood what it was and I'd gone to
other people they say what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] Mexican I wouldn't work but it
worked see the way this photo right here
that was in your movie oh that's a great
photo this photo right here that's from
that's from La Raza collection right
that's my neighborhood right there no
[ __ ] right there that's where I grew up
that's the Pico guardians housing
project right there on that corner
that's where I'm where everything
changed well I throw those killers dad
didn't even know it's like they're doing
a little protest right here man with my
life changed how so I bit some of the
ear off right there did you really love
PCP when it come on yeah story about it
nobody would heard this were I my last
time I was in my neighborhood it was
right there last time I saw it was right
there were these kids are Stan's the
beginning of him becoming a comic that's
a preschool right there and we to jump
on that preschool and jump up to the
preschool and how does that change what
what happened to you I got crazy man I
was there too a crazy fight right there
were those kids are sad be were you
really on angel dust yeah man and what
does that feel like oh man it feels like
like the whole boys like you're The
Incredible Hulk but you have no control
anything so you have incredible strength
but you don't know what do you don't
feel coordinated on it if you're
coordinated like oh yeah when I woke up
the next day I was full of blood I look
like a walking dead people you've been
in conflicts yeah you don't even feel
pain that was a little painful but the
what happened was you good that guy came
after you I guess Orson you were afraid
they were gonna come after you there you
go all right
the story that guy was the hospital
he didn't wanna press charges what
Oh didn't wanna press charges so he's
they gonna kill me I guess now if you
ever sees me again
so for a father Greg Boyle from homeboy
industries sure he put me into rehab I
know where it's where we have for about
a year
is it before homeboy is out for the
future you were addicted to that stuff
no addicted to crack and violence yeah
so how did you get to become a comedian
after all that oh when I came on a rehab
so what's the library and I asked the
librarian how to help me find books on
comedy writing and she found me this
book called Jean Perez comedy writing
step by step yeah another one Steve
Allen
no [ __ ] yeah during rehab though you
made that list yeah five things that you
wanted to do in your life it was one of
the counselors who was a priest right
yeah he told you guys to make them list
the five things you wanted you want to
know like um
write down your fight dreams yeah what
you want to do so my first dream was
well I had this dream where I'm holding
my and when I wake up is gone and
another dream where I'm naked in class
they give it a list bag you know but
your dreams your goals they don't like
soccer
no yeah what you want to be in life all
so like I don't even know what I want to
be in life and I was twenty I have no
thirteen I rode West I want to be a
comedian because I saw this album of
Bill Cosby my brother Russell home I
sleep with and there now I want then I
love Olive Garden so I want to go to on
it I wanna go to Italy and then down you
know hard decisions right here to write
down that's really hard third one to be
happy four and five I forgot so when I
came on a rehab I knew that I wanted to
be a comedian so that wrote it down so I
said I got a push push push
so here we are man talking to fellow
award-winning tells that story on the
this is not happening which is a Comedy
Central series and it's on YouTube you
it's really well told in that yeah are
you suggesting it wasn't we'll do know
this was condensed version here yeah the
other one was documentary a mockumentary
about notorious that's him and amid the
world's killer are there from other
great wrote documentaries about
comedians that did you you like know
what one yes actually it's one and it
was an HBO movie and it was there
already but Robert DeNiro and it was on
Lenny Bruce I mean it was good that's
the one I'd know there was actually
based on a comedian that was a good one
you saw which a probably what he liked
right yeah the icon was real good but
the one with uh did the one without
brother that was real really well yeah I
gotta see it and also though that uh the
ask the Oscar of course does that the
one I saw two dogs awesome
oh yeah well the actor the actor is a a
guy named Jesse said I don't and you
know he worthy from he's from here it's
mean he's from where's he from
he's from like what's that place
Bakersfield home bro Bakersfield how did
you miss the casting call for this movie
you know it's great because he really
would have been a great Bob because uh
you really would have been a great
Buffalo no china shop in our house how
do you look in a wife-beater
[Laughter]
Tom that's right but Jesse celadon is a
great actor and a guy named Jeff harms
plays a Thompson with a good cast of
weather yeah thank you yeah wait and uh
and it was fun you got you dress up as
as hunter and and an Oscar no we did for
Halloween like yeah are two years ago in
do anything less the world if you're in
low dealer did you find ridiculous I
find it just keep talking a lot of the
mood they to shoot it took about what we
what we did we took a month we um
we rented a mausoleum we didn't have
much money so there was this mortuary in
East LA and they were really great and
they let us
clear the dead bodies out and we shot on
a green screen there and we use the
embalming room where they you know dress
up the bodies we move those bodies out
and we did the makeup in there so it was
a month and then editing takes a while
you know it takes you kind of put all
[ __ ] together particularly when you
don't know what you're doing like me and
then we came up with a picture that
really like yeah so we're uh we're often
a good scene everywhere I get him happy
about it you should I don't feel shot it
on 4k yeah you know format so if we were
if I read Avro right it's the same thing
they're all the same
no there's yeah that was a brand but
that's the same technology ultimately
it's about the lenses and then yeah so
wouldn't you see another big screen
looks really beautiful um if there was
gonna be a documentary about you what
would it would it be about your life and
a button see you want and performance
and a lot of offstage stuff you know
what
Philippe is the kind of guy that you can
follow around all over LA and his
interaction with everyday people is
interesting just as interesting is there
anything else he does so when working
with Joyce was great because he you know
he has a lot of opinions about
everything George is ready right now you
know he's he's uh he's got a lot of edge
and a lot of rage and he sought up he's
very insightful about a lot of things
how's Paul doing I see working on the
wire together he's a good guy actually
main part of jjigae doing Honolulu yeah
it went right e oh yeah oh great we were
together a lot actually we were in
Tucson last summer with war Marlow
Indiana that's real G's huh real G's
what's up fool we will find your um find
you well give it a stir man yeah down to
wait a second isn't there Instagram
Instagram
brown buffalo film well
yes round Buffalo Phil Roth please find
us on instagram at brown Buffalo film
and on Facebook at brown Buffalo film uh
no in the movie was Oscar prom queen in
that photo no he was prom he was dating
the problem yeah I think he you know he
was dating the prom queen it was right
he was setting a white Jake yeah you
know he was top of the cast he was a
seat he was a class president on the
junior class and he was a varsity
football and he was the clarinet kid and
he was succeeding he was his fat little
Mexican boy he got himself slimmed down
and he out was very bright so he went to
the top he was charismatic so it became
the top of the social heap and then he
wanted to date the little white eita and
he did until her old man said it's
typical la bamba story right and the old
man says no no no no you're not
and that really busted Oscar up felt
anger and shame and the judge apparently
I don't know how apocryphal these
stories are but the judge says you know
you can either go to jail or join the
airforce
so then Oscar joined the airforce where
he played in the marching band in Panama
and because all the other soldiers he
was with all the guys in the Air Force
wanted to go to the whorehouses because
Panama was a real Panama had the highest
rate of the venereal disease among any
American base in the world and Oscar it
was kind of a straight-laced kid so he
converted to Baptist religion and he
became a Baptist minister and then he
went out in the jungles to convert the
natives it's about this so became want
to do that or we did part time he did he
died that I don't all the time line
exactly but he drops out of this service
and he becomes a Baptist and he says but
I became the Mexican Billy Graham and
then you know and it's unbelievable I
mean this is all really actually happens
and then at some point he realizes that
it's a crock of [ __ ] that he's selling a
white man's religion to these poor
Indians and he felt terrible and he
actually tries to jump out of a hotel
window jumps out of a hotel window in
orleans and he falls on a car thankfully
and he doesn't die and he says I'm
quitting God right as of this day and
then he's lost again
so he kept he was a bipolar right so he
was get all really high and really get
excited about stuff and there was no
medication there was no diagnosis he
didn't even know what he had
he couldn't address it in any way he
just kept but he kept on trying looking
for truth for peace and then he'd
medicate himself once the 60s hit he
goes off this is great because he takes
acid like aspirin to try to get his mind
straight and in a way he did in a way to
battle his bro and balance yeah and and
and when he when did this courtroom
sometimes his most inspired courtroom
strategies were come up with on on
hallucinogens that that would be wonder
what he was but then uh who liked the
camera he little hidden news right like
like he was Johnnie Cochran before
Johnnie Cochran great point and out and
actually do it fighting the same the
same the same kind of law against the
police but then he stayed up but he'd be
speaking and looking for the most
interest Chicana in the room haha
work in the room one time one time who
the player right you know he was a
player so one time he's in a courtroom
and he said he loved to bro he sees a
lumpy this black woman in the jury box
in this kind of nice leg and he's you
know he's trying this case and she's
winking at him and he's winking back and
she calls him up late at night one time
she says Mr lost dog there's some
irregularities in this jury they're
against you and there's some monkey
business so you know he spends a night
with her and they're doing the deed and
in the end he's able to call a mistrial
and get his clients free because he was
able to successfully appeal to this
black woman who was a juror so Oscar had
you know he had Wiles he had he had game
but don't do you think he kind of did a
disservice to his the people he was
representing to some extent because he's
because you know the top thing in a
courtroom is respect and he's flying in
the face of that kind of on the edge but
over the edge very often but he's
messing up the case you could lose cases
just based on your attitude I mean I've
seen so many attorneys kiss-ass like
especially when you're on the other side
and yeah so we're desperate to win but
maybe that's he was working for free a
lot of times so you know I think you'd
have to ask each each defendant to see
what they thought about it well
certainly in some case at the point that
he was trying to pitch to that she kind
of activists was it I'm not just gonna
hear to get you off a case this is about
to make a bigger point precisely we're
gonna use your persecution as a way to
advertise the persecution of our home a
whole lot of the injustice of the system
so these people were ready to take it an
L yes and I think in fairness very often
there were other lawyers there were
there were mall deaf lawyers or ACLU
lawyers also in the stable an Oscar
became the face the front it was he was
the Cochran right he was a showman and
in doing so he was able to press the
authorities and the police departments
and the Sheriff Department and and and
punish them they didn't like him because
he was so effective and he was like he
was like a trumpian figure in that way
right he's really good on camera and
people want to watch him he was
compelling like most crazy people are
and he was just something you wanted to
see and so he knew how to press their
buttons so it leads us to the to another
episode in his life when he runs for
sheriff Los Angeles County he's got no
money he's got enough just enough money
for posters and bumper stickers
there is no campaign there's a little
office somewhere there's just the rot
the locals and whatever he can come
together with and he gives 100,000 votes
it's crazy and in doing so of course he
loses by a million but he he in doing so
he makes a point he uses that platform
to make a point about police brutality
about who the police represent and who
they don't and he gets heard so yeah
absolutely
and yet and yet the guy is a marginal
figure in American
the fact that Latinos themselves don't
even know about it
yeah it's astonishing like what the [ __ ]
is wrong so actually we did a five-part
podcast in the company - the film that
we're gonna put on the on the radio that
explains a bit more things more in-depth
because I think that Oscar merits
people's awareness and again if that
doesn't note its own life its own
history its own story you just
completely beholden to the storytelling
of other groups yeah that have all the
[ __ ] money that have all the
distribution capacity to have all the
publicity orgy they can throw at you to
buy into their their interpretation of
reality and that doesn't serve us
because they got an agenda storytelling
always has an agenda right yeah comedy
always has an agenda and has a point of
view and has an experience it comes from
it's not just Suey generous it comes out
of a historical experience Lenny Bruce
very decidedly came out of a place and
so it's important as you're ingesting
entertainment as you're ingesting
comedies you're ingesting story that you
know what is the [ __ ] agenda here who
and whose interest is that I [ __ ]
chuckle here because I might be
chuckling at my own goddamn expense and
that's usually the case right yeah man I
mean there's a reason that there are
people on top to have a lot of [ __ ]
money and there's a reason that people
are eating [ __ ] on the bottom and
there's a lot of reasons for it but one
of them is how narrative gets organized
distributed made approved written about
reviewed it's an apparatus of and I
don't mean this in a paranoid way in a
conspiratorial way but it's an apparatus
of cultural control so this must be
challenged and we must have people that
are aware and awake and be able to speak
to this issue of media literacy come on
kids whoo what the [ __ ] are you
ingesting you know well suppose G what
you would add nothing man those [ __ ]
out great thank you very much for doing
that and actually bringing a story to
life and hopefully
many more people March 23rd on PBS 9
p.m. 9 p.m. and no Oscar story how much
research did you damage an infinite
amount of research a lot you know a lot
a lot you know we had a great team of
writer David Ventura and and and people
Allyson Sotomayor the producer and we
dug in and we found everything we could
find talk to people call people who
hated him and people hang up on you his
ex-wife his breath at Kuni all the way
like spoon the other we hated the
[ __ ] you said he killed my
sister gave her hepatitis and you know
from his needle use so I mean you know I
mean it was great it was a great
adventure very it's like an Easter egg
hunt and what happened to him
essentially would that great question
it's a it's a it's a mystery right there
was no trace of his body ever found
there was no record I mean that's from
it was Sinaloa my son live right and
this is then but these are proto
Nauticals and he was doing you know he
says he was gonna go make a deal and I
think Malta at least coca probably gone
here or there he wanted to come back on
a boat from mazatlán to the Bay Area to
do some business he was talking about
trading arms he was talking about making
a revolution against Nixon about Cena
against the United States of America
with the Mexican revolutionaries and the
vato locals so you know he had big
dreams big dreams very little foundation
but big dreams and somewhere you know so
we don't know and that's great to know
Twitter Philip I do what is it I have a
Twitter called brown Buffalo PBS Brown
everybody follow Brown Buffalo PBS now
Twitter yeah on Twitter what's up fool
yeah man that's crazy broad if not other
stuff it's really nuts dude all that
stuff he did I mean and from you know
from where he came from El Paso to you
know yeah but not everybody talked about
everybody
everybody all about memes both protect
all these memes but no one step it up
and say you know one day I'm gonna
represent some of these that I got for
free oh yeah man when you know where
that lawyer stepping up you know MALDEF
is great this guy tom signs it runs
modeled off his Mustang going she should
be on the show I don't know how much a
sense of humor he has but he's a
fantastic guy he's a fantastic guy when
you're out there in the audiences do you
see that politics are changing do you
get a sense that people are more
Restless or babies tell me but just no
flakes out there crying I mean they
don't take a person to take it to person
like it like like it I always tell
people like when if you don't wanna
write about me I'll tell him don't write
my jobs on paper it's not the same
people need beers people need to come
from doing something crazy like a bad
like I'm a horrible job to sit down and
to listen to me and do my comedy and I'm
saying everything they think but don't
want to say cause I don't wanna do their
jobs I'm doing it for them so I never
gonna censor myself
that's my compressional a lot of these
people that there's a lot of afraid of
their own shadow they're afraid to say
something offensive to their boss I
guess I get a lot yeah the friends that
are like professors what's our problem
probably working here for a long time
where you just starting here I got a
mortgage you know what isn't that isn't
that the case yeah this it seems like a
lot of cowardness a cowardice a lot of
people turn into the parents okay bro
people say bro I like I don't understand
like [ __ ] I can't help I can't do it no
more broad cuz I got a job with Disney
now but you go to more political before
[ __ ] yeah jump or Disney bro I can't
I can't be political boy I feel like
that you see a combination of things you
see at your shows the the portion of
these social justice warriors who come
down on him it's very small it's just a
smattering but it's an indication and
this is what this younger generation is
talking about as thinking every they're
triggered by certain words and phrases
without hearing the whole thing you know
our understanding
how this could also open doors to
communication you know or story or
conversation discussion about these
issues the comedy is another way at that
but I say also see people who are burned
out by any discussion on any side of
politics and they want a place to go
where they don't have to hear it and
that's what happened with the matter
yeah no matter what they believe or who
they support or don't support they don't
want to hear they want a place where
they can go and escape that discussion
for a while you know it's in their face
on Facebook and they're fighting with
their aunt about something on Twitter
and you get so incensed and then you
just need a little place to go time out
of mind yeah but there is a catharsis
that happens in your shows right think
they're there they're letting something
off some steam alright and how do you
understand that what are they what are
they my t-shirts how do you deal with
like people who see you as a hero and
when they look at you and they're it's
all starry-eyed and [ __ ]
is that a creepy feeling is that a good
feeling what does that feel like I love
man I'm almost code this cat did to me
you're my hero bro I let go cope you
became somebody and I ho yeah bro you
could do it to medium you could become
somebody to put the pipe down go watch
your kids go for a walk did you keep
that big guitar I'm a little cord so two
cores bro dan dan in a solo
I thought the enters the ending so yeah
so would you look up to it in the heart
race film I don't know how much you know
my I was mad my dad was from South
Central and he was a poor kid but he was
kind of a loner and and very but he was
bookish so methey Korean War he served
in the war in the army and he got a GI
bill so he got a house and he got to be
a Dakota Kelly it would go to college
and the federal government paid for it
in those days so he's able to go to UCLA
and and he was because he was
and he was isolated a very solitary
person he read a lot and then he also
watched movies a lot and he listened to
music a lot so I had this great benefit
of this father that had very kind of
working-class poor origins and he was
always haunted by that but also had a
lot of interests and movies were one of
them so as a boy you take me to them
those days it was the art houses there
was no cable TV there was three channels
for chrissakes yeah and take me the art
houses and watch the movies and watch
the French movies and the buñuel movies
and it was great
so by the time I get to 15 and I start
seeing us be able to see being Spielberg
was like get the [ __ ] out of here with
that I wanted nothing to do with it I
didn't understand what's going on it was
popcorn sales man it was dead flat
lifeless bones get the [ __ ] out of here
with that I was I was out and I just
didn't relate didn't want any Star Wars
I didn't understand what was going on it
was to me like a [ __ ] hustle I felt
like a capitalism was so efficient
juggernaut trying to sell me goddamn
merchandise and I said that's not what I
want to do and so I did something that's
much less renew Murrah t'v but to me
turns me on it gets me excited makes me
want to do it and so that's what I've
been after was so full parka with Philip
Rodriguez yeah isn't very Bob's Buffalo
film on Instagram and go watch the movie
man on PBS
it'll be an inner clock Mars man o'clock
March 24th
it'll be out for a while right yeah
beyond that day then it'd be on PBS
Digital so pbs.org or something like
that well gee waiting shows coming up he
says Hawaii
no in April and this is and part of it
is doing your books and everything that
you take for granted every day
and your podcast and your live shows do
tell hey the other night really before
he closed it the other night like she
told man I lost 10 pounds I lost 12 12
midnight
I made her the best grilled cheese ever
he did he sabotaged me
[Laughter]
what's up fool podcast man everybody man
thank you for listening
thank you for all your comments I read
them sometimes you know I don't allow
you guys are truck drivers and you
listen to are you learning our stuff and
you follow the stuff that we list that
we mention here man a lot of people
actually do listen and go to get the
stuff that we mentioned here like
actually somebody you signed up for your
acting teachers class yeah signed her
daughter yeah hello meaning greet but a
lobby and people did buy that book
brother one of the miller.time what
about Katt Williams and they're gonna
let you got you your movie and also that
other book random family before you go I
really had a good time here can I come
back thank you very much
what's so food shout-out to though I
want the wielders deal over there